[Music]
[Music]
hallo YouTube just Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my third
episode of most attacking chance gambit
and in this episode we are going to have
a look at the legendary Goering gambit
from the white perspective you the
opening arises after the falling model a
fool 'if i hear white can't start with
either the moody fall or Knight to f3
let's say in this game
white continue with Knight to f3 and
after Knight to c6 as expected
yup the d4 moon is on the card now the
first important point you need to know
here is black has to capture with the
pawn as if he continued with Knight
captures d4 then after the simple
continuation Knight captures d4 pawn
captures d4 and the move Queen captures
d4 now black doesn't have a knight to
Harris the white queen and that means
white queen is nicely placed at the
center of the board
so these positions are always better for
the white and that is the reason why at
this point
black generally captured with the pawn
which allows us to play this superb
attacking gambit starting with c3 so
guys this is the starting point of the
goreng gambit and as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows black and
except the second pawn or he can decline
the gambit with three different ways
which we are going to see at the end of
this video now before we dive into there
are two important point I like to
mention number one in this lecture I am
only going to provide you the overview
of this gambit and then if you really
like the gambit you can do the research
by yourself and the second important
point is lot of people ask me
where should I apply this gambit well
apart from quick and a bullet game you
will be surprised that you can use this
gambit against all level of players the
reason is very simple
at the lower level the theory is not
very well known and that's why you can
get crushing wing and on the other side
of the coin
even though let's say you are facing a
good player and he knows everything
about this gambit by end of this lecture
you will understand that with accurate
play black and only able to equalize the
game so in a nutshell you have a very
good drawing chances or might be of
winning one so without a further ado
let's get started first obviously we
need to look out what happens when black
captures the second pawn and after this
rather than sacrificing the third pawn
my recommendation is you go with the
Goering gambit proper and that is Knight
to c3 now as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows Black has
three optimal set up and against each of
them you will see some nasty surprises
now amongst all of them Bishop to b4 is
a mainline but let's see why other
setups are not good at all now the first
mortar I want to consider is where black
doesn't care about what fight plays and
he do teen leave child out this moves
such as Knight to f6 or Bishop to c5 and
aiming for a solid middle game but
unfortunately against going it's not
going to work out let's check out why so
let's say black start with any of this
moves Knight to f6 here comes the first
memory marker guys no matter whatever
black plays our next move is very
consistent
Bishop to c4 setting up a good tactical
platform okay Bishop to c5 so as you can
see at the lower level black can do
these things on a routine basis but
against going it is not going to work
out and now comes the second memory
marker whenever black plays the move
Knight to f6 and E Phi Square is not
controlled then we will meet it with E
Phi so remember Knight to f6 can be meet
with E Phi Black has two choices the
first one is obviously very bad one and
the simple reason is can you get such
yep the simple but dazzling sacrifice
which happen again in again in The
Goring gambit boom the point is after
King takes f7 and the move Queen to defy
not only White is gaining his piece back
but at the end of the scenario we have
an equal material and blacking is
completely caught at the center of the
board
now generally Aoife has been countered
with defy but again the beauty about The
Goring gambit is here we are going to
continue with he captures AB 6 and after
D captures seafood majority of the game
in the database continue with Queen
captures th however I am going to
introduce my own suggestion and that is
F captures g7 allowing black to capture
of a queen and miss place of a king but
now the beauty is we get this forcing
sequence
rook to g8 Knight to defy threatening
two things so black responses force
black has to play King to d8
how are in wood to thread and now
another forcing move Bishop to g5 here
it doesn't matter however black blocks
let's say one of my game continued with
Bishop to e7
I simply capture with the night and
after night captors c7 and the move rook
to even it is already looking quite
scary for the black camp
well again black has the only moon in
this position namely Bishop to e6 but
after this my assault continued with
Knight to d4 hooray black really cause
with the King to d7 then I can simply
Park my King in the corner and then play
the move rook to d1 and White has a hell
lot of good position so in the game my
opponent thought that okay just give up
on his six take on g7 that might walk
but unfortunately he ran straight into
the first goring gambit rare and that
occurs after Bishop captures e7 King
captures a7 and now this deciding blow
Knight to a5 and white is winning the
exchange just within 17 moves of the
game so as you can see if black
continued with Bishop to c5 Knight to f6
then he get the nasty heat with ePHI so
some of the solid and positional player
will come up with the second of his
settle and that is Bishop to e7 first
and after our trademark move Bishop to
c4 they stopped over if I advancement
with d6 saying that okay I have no
issues now I'm going to play Knight to
have sex and castle and you are clear
pond down sweetie yup to some extent it
looks like a true in this position
but here comes the second important
memory marker guys you have to remember
this important tactical pattern when
black off for this slow subtle meet with
Queen to b3 and suddenly the ab7 pawn is
a Connor Knight to f6 is not a
possibility do two simple move Bishop
captures at six so accordingly here
blackens the only good counter-attacking
move Knight to e5 but this can
successfully negotiate with the
following sequence Bishop captures f7
King to f8 and now very nice move Queen
to b4 yes indeed we are giving up the
bishop pair but in return we are getting
of a material bank and the most
important thing is again in this lines
black ink is completely misplaced and
not to forget that we have the King side
pawn majority that helped us to create
attack on this V king so picture is very
clear if black continued with any sort
of slow moves then white get a quick
upper hand in the opening so accordingly
Bishop to b4 is only move in this
position where black can fight for some
sort of advantage okay no issues we are
going to continue with our trademark
move Bishop to c4 keeping over threats
as it is so for example if black
continue with Knight to f6 we are going
to respond with ePHI and slow moves such
as d6 can be successfully met with Queen
to b3 and you can check those lines in
the PGN where I have covered them in
somewhat detail so accordingly the base
Melinda's position is Bishop capture c3
and after pawn capture c3 black and
argued that not only he is upon up but
white pawns are completely shattered on
the coincide so what can be the Moon
issue than this and yes it's right
because it's one of the main line but
you will be surprised that white even
get very fun positions even from this
ugly setup
okay black has to somehow stop the movie
Phi so d6 is a natural response
liberating though the bishop and here
what has few choices such as Knight to
g5 or the move Queen to b3 however my
recommendation is this straight forward
more castle on the Kings side first get
the King safe and now become Hallows to
create attack on the black camp the
important point you should note that
black can never play here Bishop to g4
as it successfully met with Queen to b3
so accordingly black has tried to moose
Knight to f6 and Knight to e7 well
amongst them one is a pretty bad one so
if your opponent continue with Knight to
e7 then here comes the second trap on
the table we will now straight away
assault on the Kings side with Knight to
g5 and after Castle you can easily guess
the next move yup there is no control on
h5 so the Queen literally leaping on a
Jew CH v square where he attacked two
spot and unfortunately black cannot
defend both of them well the game can be
finished very quickly and in fact this
happened in the database even against a
strong players black plays at six white
plays the very initial
Knight captures up seven and now believe
it or not but black has to give up the
Queen yes
either the Queen mu or Knight to e5 we
can simply respond with this forcing
checkmate night 2 at 6:00 check a double
discover chat King has to move and then
simplest more in the Royal Knight to g4
a 13 move miniature so again black is
forced to play the only move Knight to
f6 in this position and at first sight
it looks like Black has defended every
single thing and he has a clear upon up
but this is what I like about this
gambit the fun never ends and we can
continue with this theme attic break
ePHI setting up the third important trap
well Black has to take with the night
why what happens if he continued it and
he captures ePHI which looks again a
kind of natural move but in fact it's a
big time mistake as after Knight to g5
attacking on f7 when black castles you
will now see the potential of capturing
the c3 pawn with the b-pawn as when
white played this nasty move Bishop to
b3 by force
Blackie's and exchange down where he can
swap the Queen but that doesn't solve
the problem as that rook can't hide
anywhere
so you can see how tricky this gambit is
and black has to know a lot of moves
okay so now we look at the mainline move
Knight catches ePHI well after that my
recommendation is you should continue
with Knight captures e5 and after pawn
captures ePHI if white wish he can get
his full of the point immediately but
nope we are not going for the pawn
grabbing instead we are looking for the
attack and rightly so white should
continue with the second tactical team
Queen to b3 again black cannot castle
and you know why
here automatic bishop moves and that
poor guy is more or less trapped there
so that's right out of the equation so
black has to defend on f7 and the only
logical move here is Queen to e7 after
that we will continue with Bishop to b3
getting those lovely diagonals so that
if the Queen moves then black king will
be permanently stuck in the center so
accordingly black has the only moon in
this position namely c5 after this you
have to know some of the theory and just
remember this check guys which again
creates some headache in the black camp
if King to effect then we can play c4
and black king is clearly misplaced so
accordingly black and block the check
with either of the pieces amongst them
Knight to d7 is a pretty bad move and
the simple reason is after rook a to
Devon castle on the Kings side and now
we can just mount the pressure on d7
with Queen to d5 which forces Knight to
f6
and after that the simplest moon in the
world
Quinn capture c5 and that rook hunt down
scheme crop up again and again
and that is why it is really fun to play
such a gambit okay so that means Bishop
to d7 is forced and after that my
recognition is you go for this simple
sequence Bishop captures d7 forcing
black to capture with the night and
after that we can respond with Queen
captures b7 e hitting the rook in the
corner
black can now Castle in order to support
the rook another forcing move rook to d1
so again black has to address the week
night with rook to b8 so you can see up
to this point every single move is
forced and now comes the sting in the
team and this is what I like about the
gambit if this is the main line then
white is quite happy to go into it and
after the final deciding blow the chef's
cap to c5 white he's getting his all
material back with a huge active play
well the base response goes as follows
Quinn capture see if I now we play rook
captures d7 threatening group captures
f7 so again black response is forced
Black has to capture on d7 and here
white should capture the rook on Ed
which forces black queen to retrieve
back and after that nope we are not
interested in the Queen trade instead we
are looking to play Quint we form so by
end of this transaction not only white
get a pass C pawn but there is an attack
on e5 and all and on if this is the main
line then I am quite happy to go into
this
as lowering opponent will never reach to
this position and if we are getting this
position against a higher seed
well draw or win is pretty good result
for the white camp so in a nutshell if
you opponent accept the gambit then I
think white is quite happy as all these
variations are giving good advantage to
the white camp finally we come to the
part where we need to see what happens
if you open and decline the gambit and
amongst them the first move I want to
consider is d3 so what black is doing is
okay I'm giving you pawn back but in
return your knight cannot develop on a
national square but after Bishop
captures d3 I think it is black who is
fooling himself as now he cannot play
actively with his tax code bishop well
obviously if we continue with Bishop to
e7 then we are more than happy as black
remain very passive so the big question
arise what happens if he continued
actively with Bishop to c5 okay here is
the answer first we are going to
continue with before and after Bishop to
b6 you can either choose the moon a for
a knight to d2 and in either case it is
white who get out early Queen side space
in the game my personal preferences
Knight 2 d2 and it doesn't matter
whether black continued with a 5 or a 6
let's say a 6 we will play Knight to c4
attacking the bishop and when the bishop
retrieve the another jab in the center
if I which completely restrict the King
side night after night to e7 and castle
you can see the big problem in the black
camp as in order to free of his
LightSquared Bishop and the rook in the
corner he has to play either the move d6
or d5 and whenever this happen on the
board we can simply lop it all and cube
black this horrible d6 pawn which can be
tunnelled
a big time target in the upcoming middle
game the second more I want to consider
is Knight to f6 which again I don't like
him as it allow white to gain the space
in the center with E 5 if Knight to e4
then Queen to e2 is a very strong move
and I have a touch a sample line in the
PGN so the most frequent choice here is
Knight to d5 but after that we can
simply capture on d4 and white position
already looking quite good in the
opening day if d6 then Bishop to b5 is a
strong reply so again the most popular
choice is Bishop to b4 check but we can
safely negotiate with Bishop to d2
Bishop captures d2 and now Queen
captures d2 the point is when black
continue with d6 trying to undermine our
center we can simply respond with Knight
to c3 and it doesn't matter whether
black capture of a knight or take on e5
let's say Knight capture c3 Queen
capture c3 pawn takes e4 and pawn takes
d5 again we have the scenario where
White has the leading development and
even the best response such as Queen to
defy doesn't help at all as we can
simply continue with Bishop to e2 and
when black played the book move Queen to
b4 we can simply exchange the Queen with
Queen to c4 which leads to a position
which I personally
as wide due to the simple reason why has
the space as well as the leading
development so considering all this
factors I think probably the best
response here for black is to plead defy
counter-attacking
the white center and against this my
recommendation is you should capture on
d5 and when black recaptured you should
capture with the C pawn so the idea is
very simple we are making a way for our
c3 Knight and in my past I have created
a video with the move Knight to f6 where
I have recommended system for the black
but again those lines can only equalize
so accordingly if black want any
advantage then the mainline goes with
the move Bishop to g4 pressurizing the
default pawn but now it is white who is
going to develop with attack Knight to
c3 Bishop to b4 pinning down the knight
and now the simple move Bishop to e2 so
this was pretty much played in majority
of the games and here black has tried
two choices if we castle at this point
then this is a very risky vision as
white can castle as well and now in the
view of Queen is hanging black has to
take on c3 afterwards B capture c3 and
the move Knight to f6 the first obvious
thing you can notice here that White has
this open B file which helped him to
create attack on the black ink and the
second important feature is White has
the center and the bishop pair which is
always a deciding factor in the upcoming
middle game all in all I think as for
the data base this position is quite
favorable for the white camp
so by far the most popular line here is
Bishop captures f3 Bishop captures f3
and now black can't capture on d4 as
after Bishop capture c6 he will simply
lose the Queen so that is right out of
the equation but blacks big idea is he
wants to play Queen to see for stopping
White Castle on the King side again I
really like this lines from the white
perspective as White has this nice move
in this position Bishop captures c6
forcing black to capture with the pawn
or else if he continued with Queen
capture c6 then we can simply castle and
if black thinks that he convinced a pawn
here by doing this transaction then is
completely fooled and after rook check
Knight to e7 and the move Bishop to g5
black King will be completely remain in
the center and most likely his Knight is
going to lost in a few moves you might
say his hang on why can't black play up
6 well he can but then white pieces just
hit the Queen with rook to c1 and after
Queen to b4 and the move Bishop to f4
look to see someone is coming in the
picture and again if black tried to save
the pawn with c6 well guess what White
has tricked black and rook to be one as
a winning move so again the majority of
the game continued with be captured c6
and here white has two choices if you
want an interesting option then I can
suggest Queen to b3 and you can do the
research by you own but my
recommendation is this simple move Queen
to e2 which forces the Queen trade and
after King takes e to the net result is
yes indeed White has a weak
pawn on d4 but look at the black queen
side it has been completely shattered
and as the results shown this position
is slightly better for the white camp
that's it guys
I hope with this small video now you are
eager and confident enough to play this
gambit on the board as I have shown
throughout the lecture it doesn't matter
whether black captures the pawn or
decline overall it is white who get the
exciting package and better winning
chances thank you for watching this
video feel free to like subscribe and
comment and I will meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care